Transcriber: Kutay Cinar
Gözden geçirme: Başak Gökdaş
(Korece hoş geldiniz)
Sizi Korece selamladım.
Üç senedir Korece öğrenmeye çalışıyorum.
Maalesef öğrenemedim.
O yüzden konuşmamda sadece 10 saniye
benden Korece bir şeyler duyacaksınız.
Ama sekiz yüz doksan saniye boyunca
teknolojiyle feminizmin mücadelesini
anlatacağım size.
Çünkü en iyi bildiğim konu bu.
Biraz da merkeziyetsiz teknolojiler
gelişmeye başladıktan sonra
bu mücadele nasıl evrildiden
bahsedeceğim.
Çünkü ben de tanrıça olmaktansa cyborg
olmayı tercih edenlerdenim.
Ve varsa aranızda neden bahsettiğimi
anlamayıp bu konuda ikna olmam biraz zor
diyenler, onları da ikna
etmek için buradayım.
Elimden geleni yapacağım.
Aslında konuşmamın örgüsünden
birazcık bahsettim.
Bundan sonrasını dinleyip dinlememek için
karar verme noktasında şanslısınız.
Anahtar kelimeleri verdim:
Merkeziyetsizlik, feminizm, teknoloji
ve cyborg.
Şimdi bu konuyu tartışacağım sizlerle
beraber ama gerçekten beraber.
O yüzden şimdi birlikte cevaplayacağımız
bir soruyla başlayacağım.
Diyelim ki yerlerde cam kırıkları
veya taşlar olmayan,
hatta soğuk ve kir olmayan bir dünyada
ayakkabı giymekten vazgeçebilir miydik?
Bu kolay olan soruydu.
Muhtemelen vazgeçerdik.
Peki diyelim ki kadınların doğum izni
kullanmak zorunda olmadığı,
hatta adet dönemi yaşamak
zorunda olmadığı,
hatta fiziksel uzuvlarından
kaynaklı fiziksel kuvvetlerinin
erkeklerden nispeten daha az
olmadığı bir dünyada işleri, görevleri,
sorumlulukları, maaşları dağıtırken
cinsiyet umrunuzda olur muydu?
Cevaplayın.
Çok fazla sürem yok zaten.
15 dakika boyunca cevabınızı
düşünün bu sorulara.
Şimdi yakın dönem literatürüne baktığınız
zaman benim gibi araştırmacılar özellikle
tekno feminizm, siber feminizm müthiş
tartışmalardır, ağırlıklı bu konuya
odaklanmışlardır.
Ama ben bugün sizlere
günümüze ve geleceğe odaklanarak
merkeziyetsiz Sophia’larla,
merkeziyetsiz cyborg’larla,
bu teknoloji ve kadın arasında kurulan ve
benim gibi bazılarının
çarpık bir ilişki olduğunu düşünen,
düşündüğümüz ilişkinin nasıl
bir dönüşüm potansiyeli olduğunu
tartışmak istiyorum tam olarak.
Tabii ki de Havva'dan bahsetmeye
başlayacağım aşikar.
Hatta,
kadınların teknik eğitim alma imkanı
olmayan yıllara da götürmeyeceğim sizi ama
hep beraber bir miktar böyle
İkinci Dünya Savaşı yılları 1960′lar,
bilişim teknolojileri alanında müthiş
yüksek adetlerde kadınların çalıştığı
bir dünyada ne oldu da 70′lerin
sonlarına geldiğimizde bir anda
kadınlar teknolojiyle ilişkili sektörlerde
alanlarda üretimden çekilmeye başlamıştı,
uzaklaşmıştı veya uzaklaştırılmıştı.
Hikaye çok absürt.
Hikayede gerçekten enteresan
bir şekilde matematik yok.
Ama müthiş politik, stratejik ve kültürel
bir kurgunun ürünü bir hikaye.
Neden biliyor musunuz?
1960′lar, işte dünya savaşları falan filan
Şimdi gelecekte bugün
2020′ler diye anılacak.
2020′lere geldiğimizde birçok araştırmacı,
bilim insanı hala bu konuyu çalışıyor.
İtibarlı ve küresel Birleşmiş Milletler,
Dünya Bankası gibi platformlar
bu konuya bakıyor, araştırıyor,
raporlar yayınlıyor.
Bir sorun olduğu için iyileşme önerileri
ve aksiyonlar çıkartıyor ortaya.
Harıl harıl birileri bu konuda çalışıyor.
Ve sonuç:
Teknoloji ve bağlantılı sektörlerde
çalışan yönetici üstü kademelerdeki
kadın oranı yüzde 5′leri zorluyor.
Şimdi bu hikaye, daha yeni başladım
hikaye anlatmaya.
Hikayedeki matematik 5 rakamı.
Başka bir matematik yok
ama dediğim gibi müthiş bir kurgu var.
Şimdi bugünden geleceğe doğru
falan konuşacağız dedim ya biraz.
Bugün ne var bir de hayatınızda?
Niye buradasınız hepiniz
Sophia’nın peşinden?
Yapay zeka var, robot teknolojileri var.
Siberpunk genre’sından romanlardan
çok alışkın olduğumuz karakterler var.
Cyborg’lar, sibernetik organizmalar
ya da makine insanlar.
Nasıl hitap etmek sizi daha rahat
hissettiriyor onlara karşı.
Şimdi bunlar var ve bunların,
cyborg diyelim mesela,
alameti farikası ortalama bir insandan,
bizlerden doğal olarak daha hızlı
bilgi işleyerek üretime katkıda
bulunmaları, değil mi?
Bizim yerimize bir şeyleri
bizden daha iyi halledebiliyorlar.
Hasbel kader,
bu cyborg’lar bir takım belki ticari
kaygılar veya dikkat çekmek için
bazı üretim kademelerindeki rollerinde
kadın gibi üretiliyorlar görsel olarak.
Ama hepimiz aşağı yukarı genç arkadaşlarım
dahil biliyordur ki
biz ne Terminatör’ler gördük.
Niye dünyayı kurtaran cyborg’lar
erkek olarak bedenlendiriliyor?
Bu hikayenin böyle bir kenarda
dursun bir kısmı.
Ama ne dedim biraz önce?
Cyborg’ların,
onlara ihtiyacımız var.
Çünkü bir takım sorunları, bir takım
prosesleri, sosyal yaşam pratikleri, bize
ihtiyacımız olan bir takım şeyleri
hızlı bilgi işleme kapasiteleri ile
bizim yerimize halletsinler
diye bekliyoruz.
Neden görüntülere cinsiyetlendirilmiş
bedenleri kritik bir faktör olsun ki
burada sorusuna cevap arıyorum.
Şimdi Sophia’ya muhtemelen
hepimiz aşinayız.
En azından burada bilet
aldık geldik buraya.
Bizleri dinlemeden önce bir
Google yapmışsınızdır.
Şimdi bir de ne kadar aşinasınız veya
farkındasınız bilmiyorum
ama merkeziyetsiz cyborg’lar var.
Makine insanlar ya da fiziksel insanların
dijital uzantıları olan ama
merkeziyetsiz yeni dünyalardaki
uzantıları olan cyborg’lar var.
Bir miktar da ondan bahsedelim.
Orada neler oluyor,
onlar neler yapıyorlar?
Şimdi merkeziyetsiz
dediğim zaman bilmiyorum
bana nasıl gözlerle bakıyorsunuz?
Çok karanlık benim durduğum yerden
sizin durduğunuz yer.
Ama merkeziyet dediğim zaman bildiğiniz
merkez meselesi
ve merkez olmayan bir ortam meselesinden
bahsediyorum.
Ama bir tık teknolojik konuşmam gerekirse
hayranlarından olduğum
merkeziyetsiz teknolojiler var
ve genelde blok zincir
teknolojisi şapkası, şemsiyesi
adı altında anılıyor bunlar.
Onların da alameti farikası,
şu çağımızın
biraz muzdarip olduğumuz sorunlarından
birini gidermek.
Nedir bu? Verilerimiz ne oluyor,
verilerimiz ne olacak?
O teknolojiler yani kapalı devrelerde,
depolarda, şekillerde
dijital verileri
yönetebildiğimiz teknolojiler
ortaya çıktığından beri biz üretiyoruz.
Birileri de onları depoluyor.
Ondan sonra da şikayet ediyoruz.
Benim verilerim ile neler yapılıyor,
verilerim nerelere gidiyor
haberim olmuyor diye.
İşte geldi.
Merkeziyetsiz veri yönetişimi.
Çift taraflı bir operasyon.
Yönetim değil, yönetişimi sağlayan
teknolojilerden bahsediyorum.
Şimdi bu teknolojiler geldi, güzel veri
tabanlarına yerleşti,
merkeziyetsiz parayı bile yönetebiliyoruz.
Bir şey daha yaptılar. Bize merkeziyetsiz
dünyaların kapılarını açtılar.
Yine meraklıları bilir, oyun sektöründen
veya siberpunk genre’sı romanlarından.
‘Metaverse’ diye hepinizin
aşina olduğu şey zaten vardı.
Ama blokzincir teknolojisi gelip
altına oturduğu zaman
artık şeffaf ama
güvenilir verilerin yönetildiği,
işlerin yapılabildiği bir yer haline
geldi orası.
Ve bu ne getirdi biliyor musunuz?
Güvenilir ve tamamen gizli
anonim kimliklerle
bir şeyler yapabilme imkanını
getirdi bize.
Bir şeyler yapabilmekten kastım
sosyalleşme ile ilgili şeyler artı üretim.
Yani sözün özü merkeziyetsiz siborg
diye andığım bizler
ve diğer makine insanlar,
artık din, dil, ırk diye saymayacağım ama
cinsiyetlerinden ve fiziksel dünyadaki
kimliklerinden bağımsız
üretime, tüketime, kendilerini
özgürce ifade etmeye,
her türlü hakka eşit seviyede sahipler.
Yani teknolojiyle kadın arasında çarpık
diye nitelendirdiğim, maalesef kadını
dezavantajlı bir konuma koyarak
geliştirilmiş olan ilişki için
süper olumlu bir gelişme
görüyorum ben burada.
Şimdi çok fazla teknoloji kelimesini
kullandım, işim bu, sevdiğim alan bu.
Okumayı sevdiğim şeyler bunlar.
Ve evet teknolojinin iyileştirebileceğini
biliyorum dünyamızı.
Ama lütfen benim düşmediğim
bir yanılgı bu.
Sizler de düşmeyin.
Teknoloji insanların sorunlarını
çözmez, çözemez.
İnsanlar ancak ve ancak teknolojiyi
doğru şekilde kullanarak
sorunlarını çözebilirler.
Ve lütfen teknoloji ve kadından
bahsedildiğinde,
ağırlıklı kurumlar tarafından yapılan
şu güçlendirme projelerinden de
vazgeçelim istiyorum.
Evet, daha iyi bir dünya için,
sorunlarımızı çözmek için
teknolojiyi iyi kullanmamız lazım.
Ama bunun için de kadınlar olarak,
birilerinin bence bizleri güçlendirmeye
çalışmasına gerek yok.
Güçlendirmek kelimesiyle
müthiş bir kavgam var.
Barışamıyorum.
Neden biliyor musunuz?
Güçlendirmek,
bana yine dışardan bir otorite
veya güç kaynağının,
beni yönetmesi hissiyatını veriyor.
Kadınlar güçlenebilir arkadaşlar.
Ama nasıl biliyor musunuz?
Belki de böyle sözlerimi
bitirmeye yaklaşırken
hemen araya bunu da sıkıştırmaktan
çok mutlu olacağım.
İçten gelen özgürleşme ile güçlenmek en
güzelidir ve en büyük tavsiyem de
herhalde kadınlara bunu
deneyimlemeleri olacaktır.
Şunu söylemeyi de çok istedim.
Hâlâ birazcık zamanım varken sanırım
en kıymetli tüketme şekli bu
olacak benim için.
Lütfen hepiniz teknolojiye kendi
gözlerinizden bakın.
Cesaretinizi toplayın ve
teknolojinin iyileştireceği bir dünyaya
kendi bakış açınızdan,
kendi gözlerinizden bakın
ve herkesin sizin gözlerinizden
bakmasını sağlayın.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Korece Teşekkürler)